العلاقه كانت متوتره جدا لانه فور خروج
السودانيين قاده الحركه من المعتقلات بعد
المصالح الوطنيه في عام 77 طرحت مساله
التنظيم الدولي
وبالمقابل طرح الترابي والقياده السودانيه
انه لا يؤمنون بتنظيم دولي لحركه اسلاميه
عربيه ولكن يؤمنون بتنسيق عام بين حركات
الاسلام في العالم كلها العربيه
والباكستانيه والافريقيه وفي امريكا وفي
اوروبا وكان هذا بمصابه صدمه كبيره لانه
وفقا للائحه الارشاد عام 1948 ان
التنظيمات الاخوان العربيه هي فروع
للتنظيم الام في مصر فاعتبروا ان ذلك
تمردا من الحركه وخاصه من الترابي يريد ان
يكون مركزا وزعامه ووسمت هذه العلاقه طيله
سنوات
الفتره التي سبقت الانقاز وبعضا من فتره
الانقاص وقام هنالك تنظيم اخر صغير باسم
الاقوال المسلمين بقياده الشيخ صادق عبد
الله عبد الماجد كان يبذل البيعه للتنظيم
الام في مصر وكان بعضا من التنظيم الدولي
ولكن تنظيم السودان لم يكن ابدا بعضا من
التنظيم الدولي